One consequence of Hollywood being
dominated by superheroes and franchises
is that by the time you're my age,
you've seen about 6,000
action,
second summer spectacular.
Many are not,
and it's pretty easy to distinguish
between the two because the reaction is
physical as adrenaline being released
into your system or not,
are you gripping your armrest or not?
After watching all these set pieces,
I think we've sort of been forced to
develop an intuitive sophistication
about them.
There are no shortcuts to thrilling and
audience that's absolutely drowning in
this stuff.
We recognize and champion good work when
we see and feel it.
I think that's the secret to the success
of franchises like mission impossible,
fast and furious,
and John Wick.
These are movies that are committed to
weld,
choreographed well edited,
real action,
okay.
Not always.
Real cruise understands exactly what
he's offering.
The three or four genuinely creative set
pieces with a serviceable plot that
doesn't take itself too seriously and a
few charismatic actors can be a really
fun movie going experience well worth
the price of.
Okay.
In fact,
this formula I think in many ways
defines the strategy of the marvel
cinematic universe.
Some of those movies are undoubtedly
better than this.
Some unfortunately worse,
but they've tried their best to hew to
this baseline and I think it's worked
out pretty well for them.
Anyone else?
Every ingredient matters of course,
but the marvel set pieces have been
really consistent by enlarge and they're
probably the things that I remember most
when I think back on these movies now I
know there's a certain amount of fatigue
these days about superhero films.
I feel that way too.
More and more,
but you know,
if I ever think back to my expectations
as a kid for what big screen superhero
team up fights would be like.
I mean,
there's definitely exceeds the laws of
physics at all.
There's a lot going on here that you
don't understand that.
The sad part about this is that as a kid
I read DC comics,
not marvel comics,
and unfortunately the DC extended
universe set pieces leave a lot to be
desired.
There are a lot of reasons for this,
I think that people have explored before
Zack Snyder's preference for stylized
coloring versus the more muted
cinematography of the mcu.
The overuse of super slow motion and
ridiculous virtual camera moves like
this,
but there are a few other things I want
to point out that I think make a bigger
difference when it comes to superhero
set pieces.
The first is that physics matters,
but we all know that superheroes do a
lot of absurd things.
Half the shots that iron man takes would
he fatal blows,
but people have an intuitive sense for
weight and velocity impact,
which is why in camera action usually
get some more visceral response from
audiences.
The physics are absolutely real.
This doesn't mean that all CGI is bad,
but if you're going to use CGI,
it's a good idea to pay a lot of
attention to the cues that people pick
up.
And then the first set piece of winter
soldier,
for example,
the Russo brothers do a great job at
gauging captain America strength level
for the audience with only a few shots.
They lace these in with real hand to
hand combat to enhance the realism or
take spiderman heavily CG character.
It's easy to establish his physics
because he's swinging on elastic bands
and it's a different type of physics
than Iron Mans or the hoax.
Too often in DC movies,
the physics just don't matter,
or the camera is doing something that
makes everything feel weightless.
Taking away the real force of a punch.
For example,
I don't even understand the physics of
how my toes and there's not enough
difference between the heroes for the
audience to really feel the power
levels.
Nothing is graceful or tactical.
It's all just brute force.
Which brings me to my second point is
scan st agnes.
Use powers creatively,
first time for everything.
Angela.
It's not always the case,
but there's a good number of times in
the marvel movies where powers interact
off of one another in ways that you
can't predict how our full hundred
percent capacity.
How about that?
Or they take something routine like
someone bailing from a car and just go
the extra step to DC films.
Every character is a blunt instrument,
only doing the most obvious thing,
which in Superman's case is usually.
This frustrates me so much because
superman has a laundry list of powers.
There has to be some way for him to
combine them in a creative way to solve
a problem or defeat a clever villain.
I know a good filmmaker can figure it
out.
Finally,
the one thing that marvel is really good
at is the ability to slip character
moments into the cracks of big set
pieces.
Every action scene has its pauses.
When everything stops in the characters,
get to say a line or two for the simple
things like how much this is.
Here are the things that marvel
character set on those pauses.
Bulk funding meets you guys be more
handsome and taking on a squadron,
and he didn't invite me,
man,
who was laden with Alaska one time where
you're from Queens,
Brooklyn.
Now here are the things that DC
characters say.
I'm going to stop here.
You ever estimate through,
so we'll see about that.
Next time they shine your light in the
sky.
Don't go into crafting good set pieces,
won't solve all the problems plaguing
the EU.
They can't make for a good movie alone,
but I think you'd be surprised how much
people forgive when they've had a
genuinely bracing experience at the
theater.
Eventually the people behind the DC,
you.
We'll figure it out until then.
I'm afraid it's just going to be a whole
lot of this.
Hey everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has a beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from that makes that process super
simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.